Bonjour, avez-vous déjà entendu parler
de cette troublante histoire,
celle des esclaves oubliés de l'île Tromelin?
Perdue au cœur de l'océan Indien,
entre Madagascar et l'île de la Réunion,
l'Île Tromelin est aussi nommée l'île
de Sable, un lieu imprégné
d'histoire et de mystères.
Pourquoi des esclaves ont-ils été
abandonnés sur un simple banc de sable?
Combien de temps sont ils restés sur cette
île?
Qu'ont-ils mis en place pour survivre?
Et surtout, est-ce qu'il reste encore
des traces de leur passage aujourd'hui?
De nombreux archéologues ont
mené l'enquête et nous délivrent
un récit bouleversant.
Et pour vous raconter cette histoire
fascinante, je serai accompagné de Doc
Seven, qui parraine ce troisième épisode.
Bienvenue dans Cabinet Curiouz.
Nous sommes en 1760,
le navigateur français Jean de Lafargue
est missionné par la Compagnie des Indes Orientales
pour ravitailler les colonies
françaises de l'océan Indien.
Il prend le large à partir de Bayonne,
à bord d'un navire nommé L'Utile.
Il joint un deuxième navire nommé L'agréable,
d'où l'expression
"joindre l'utile à l'agréable".
C'est faux !
Il n'y a qu'un seul navire.
C'est L'Utile qui va arriver à destination,
l'île Maurice, en avril 1761.
La même année, il reprend la route,
direction Madagascar.
Et c'est à ce moment précis
que les ennuis commencent.
À bord de ce bateau se trouvent 142
marins, mais aussi 160 esclaves malgaches
enfermés dans la cale.
Il faut savoir
à l'époque que la traite négrière est
interdite par le gouverneur de l'île
Maurice, pour ne pas avoir à nourrir
des bouches supplémentaires alors
qu'ils sont en pleine famine.
Le capitaine et ses matelots cachent
donc les esclaves dans la soute
dans le but de les revendre en douce
sur l'île Maurice. Et pour prendre
encore moins de risques,
le capitaine fait un très gros détour
vers le nord pour éviter les contrôles.
Manque de pot, pendant ce détour,
tard dans la soirée du 31 juillet 1761,
le navire se fracasse sur le récif
corallien qui entoure une toute petite île
de 1 kilomètre carré, l'île de Tromelin.
Sur les 302 personnes à bord,
on ne compte qu'environ 200
survivants, dont 80 esclaves.
Le reste d'entre eux étant enfermé
à double tour dans les cales.
C'est plus de 100 malheureux
qui meurent noyés.
Dans la foulée, les marins ne perdent
pas de temps.
En quelques semaines seulement,
ils construisent une embarcation
de fortune grâce aux restes de l'épave.
Mais il y a quand même un gros
problème qui se pose à eux.
Cette embarcation, nommée La Providence,
n'est pas du tout assez grande
pour transporter tout le monde.
Les 122 marins embarquent,
abandonnant lâchement les 60 esclaves
qui ont survécu jusque là, en leur
promettant qu'ils reviendront
les chercher avec de l'aide.
La question est donc :
sont ils vraiment revenus?
Les premières heures,
puis les premiers jours passent et malgré
le soleil, le manque d'eau
et de nourriture et la météo capricieuse,
ils décident de faire tout ce qui est
en leur pouvoir pour survivre.
Ils usent d'ingéniosité et de créativité
pour conserver cet élan de vie
dans ce milieu si hostile.
Vous allez être surpris d'apprendre ce
que ces soixante naufragés sont capables
de faire sur une si petite île,
qui ne possède vraiment pas grand chose comme ressource.
Maxime Guérout, archéologue, très renommé
pour ses travaux de recherche
en archéologie sous-marine,
a piloté quatre expéditions archéologiques
sur l'île de Tromelin entre 2006 et 2013,
pour étudier ce naufrage
et la survie de ces 80 rescapés.
Les fouilles ont fait émerger des choses
plus que surprenantes.
L'île étant entièrement vierge,
les naufragés récupèrent et exploitent
chacun des objets restants de l'épave.
Ils construisent de grandes bassines
en cuivre pour récupérer l'eau de pluie.
Ils fabriquent aussi des bols,
des cuillères.
Ils creusent des puits jusqu'à atteindre
de l'eau saumâtre, une eau dont la teneur
en sel est bien inférieure à celle
de la mer.
Le feu étant
un élément tout aussi primordial,
ils fabriquent aussi des briquets,
un précieux objet pour allumer
le feu en cas de temps agité.
En effet, cette île subit régulièrement
des tempêtes tropicales,
voire des cyclones.
Max Guérout a également découvert
une lettre fascinante qui décrit
leur quotidien.
Pour rester en vie,
ils mangent des oiseaux
et des tortues de mer.
Ils se créent des pagnes à l'aide
de plumes d'oiseaux pour se couvrir
et construisent des habitations
très ingénieuses.
Il faut savoir que sur cette île,
le vent souffle en permanence.
Pour se protéger des puissantes
bourrasques, les naufragés construisent
d'épaisses murailles de corail.
Les murs vont jusqu'à un mètre soixante
et leur épaisseur est
de quasiment trois mètres.
Ces maisons de pierre et de corail sont
justement la découverte la plus étonnante
puisque la structure créée est très
innovante et très éloignée des habitudes
de construction de la société malgache.
Chaque construction est organisée autour
d'une cour centrale dont les bâtisses
s'adossent les unes aux autres,
ce qui n'est pas le cas à Madagascar,
où les maisons sont traditionnellement
construites dans un enclos individuel.
Pour Max Guérout, cela témoigne d'une
forte solidarité parmi les naufragés.
Par ailleurs,
les esclaves vont transgresser un interdit
lourd de sens dans leur culture.
En effet, pour construire leurs habitations,
ils vont utiliser des pierres.
Or, dans la culture malgache,
les pierres sont exclusivement
réservées à la conception des tombeaux.
En bref, ils ont bâti une véritable
micro-société, avec ses propres codes
sociaux et sa nouvelle culture.
C'est ce qu'affirme Thomas Romon,
archéologue,
qui explique que ces individus ont
reconstruit une société ensemble. Et on se
rend compte qu'ils sont allés au-delà
de la simple survie puisqu'ils
ont aussi fabriqué des objets
au-delà de l'utilitaire et du fonctionnel.
Mais comment cette histoire
s'est-elle terminée?
L'équipage, lui, finit par arriver
à Madagascar.
Dans la foulée,
le lieutenant du navire L'Utile prévient
les autorités et essaie par tous les
moyens de retourner sauver les naufragés.
Malheureusement, le gouverneur de l'île
Maurice, furieux que son interdiction
de traite n'ait pas été respectée,
refuse catégoriquement.
Le lieutenant envoya même une lettre,
environ dix ans plus tard, au ministre
de la Marine lui-même, pour le supplier
d'aller voir.
C'est un petit peu long
pour une saison de Koh-Lanta...
Et pourtant, une lueur d'espoir pointe
le bout de son nez lorsque les naufragés
voient arriver un navire envoyé
spécialement pour les secourir,
nommé La Sauterelle.
Le bateau jette l'ancre et envoie
deux marins sur un petit canot pour aller
chercher les esclaves.
Plan qui tombe malheureusement à l'eau
puisque le canot se
fracasse contre les coraux.
L'un des marins rejoint La Sauterelle
à la nage, tandis que l'autre,
sûrement moins bon nageur...
je ne sais pas trop...
se retrouve coincé sur l'île.
Entre temps, les récifs ont coupé le câble
de l'ancre de La Sauterelle,
qui doit alors rentrer à l'Île de France,
c'est l'ancien monde de la Réunion,
en laissant une personne de plus
sur l'île de Tromelin.
Le matelot, abandonné par ses
compagnons, reste bloqué là pendant
des mois et arrive à construire un radeau
de fortune avec lequel il quitte l'île,
accompagné de trois
hommes et trois femmes.
L'embarcation ne sera jamais retrouvée.
Après la tentative
de rescousse de la sauterelle,
il a fallu trouver une âme suffisamment
charitable pour aller risquer son bateau
là où d'autres ont fait naufrage.
Tout ça pour sauver quelques
esclaves au bout de leur vie...
si ils sont encore en vie...
C'est seulement quelques années plus tard,
le 29 novembre 1776, qu'un nouveau navire,
La Dauphine, viendra clore
la tragédie de ces esclaves oubliés.
La fin d'un calvaire qui aura duré 15 ans.
Le nom de l'île vient d'ailleurs
du capitaine de ce navire,
Jacques-Marie de Tromelin.
Et quelle surprise
en découvrant les survivants.
Enfin, je devrais dire les survivantes.
En effet, les huit personnes vivant là-bas
sont sept femmes et un bébé de huit mois.
Au final, ce seront une cinquantaine
de personnes qui auront perdu la vie
là bas.
Selon les archéologues,
les personnes sont mortes de faim
ou de soif peu après le naufrage.
Et pour les autres,
selon le témoignage des sept femmes,
un groupe de 18 naufragés aurait tenté
de prendre la mer à bord d'un radeau
de fortune qui n'a probablement
jamais touché terre.
Ce que l'on sait du destin des 8 rescapés,
c'est qu'elles ont refait leur vie à l'île
Maurice et qu'elles ont fermement refusé
de retourner vivre à Madagascar
de peur de redevenir des esclaves.
La psychanalyste Daniela Gariglio prend
aujourd'hui l'île de Tromelin comme un
exemple de résilience et de volonté.
Elle explique que les survivants
de Tromelin sont la démonstration
scientifique du fait que quand la pulsion
de vie s'allie à la pulsion créatrice, on
peut survivre en se réinventant une vie.
Max Guérout dit d'ailleurs que cette
tragédie est sans doute l'illustration
la plus extrême,
la plus révoltante de l'horreur qu'ont
été la traite négrière et l'esclavage.
Mais l'ingéniosité et la farouche volonté
de vivre des naufragés sont aussi
un triomphe sur la barbarie
de leurs bourreaux.
Dites-moi quels sujets vous rêveriez
de voir dans Cabinet Curiouz.
Vous me dites dans l'espace commentaires
et j'irai faire mon marché à l'intérieur.
Merci beaucoup à Doc Seven d'avoir
parrainé cette chaîne il
y a quelques années déjà,
et aujourd'hui, ce troisième
épisode du Cabinet Curiouz.
Je vous mets un lien vers sa
chaîne dans la description.
Je vous invite à le découvrir.
Il y a énormément de vidéos
sur plein de sujets très curieux.
Si vous ne connaissez pas également mon
magazine qui s'appelle Curiouz,
qui existe maintenant depuis 14 ou 15 numéros.
C'est un magazine papier
mensuel de plus de 52 pages.
On passe bientôt à 62 pages.
Je vous invite à regarder le lien
également dans la description.
C'est un magazine
qui assouvit la curiosité du cerveau et ça
sort tous les mois,
dix numéros par an,
directement dans vos boîtes
aux lettres pour 29 euros 90.
Quant à moi, je m'appelle
toujours Fabien Olicard.
Ça ne change pas,
c'est très pratique !
Je vous invite à vous abonner à cette chaîne,
à activer la cloche pour ne pas rater
les prochaines vidéos
et à liker cette vidéo
si elle vous a plu.
Ici,
je vous mets deux autres vidéos :
les deux premiers Cabinet Curiouz,
l'un sur l'île de la Rose et l'autre
sur l'affaire Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès.
Prenez soin de vous!
A très bientôt.
Tchao!